[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a korean comedy drama film
called granny's got talent
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the movie is an old
woman known as granny she has been
living in prison for the past few
decades for not paying her debts a day
before getting out she boasts about her
son's achievements to her cellmates her
older son works in a prestigious company
while her younger one is a musician
despite both of them having different
fathers they are both diligent like her
granny gets out of the prison the next
day but no one comes to pick her up
while she is in a subway she witnesses a
middle-aged man harassing a young girl
since no one else intervenes she speaks
up for the girl and cusses the man the
entire crowd is stunned to hear her
vocabulary of curse words granny's been
to jail they'd be even more stunned if
she shanked him at the next stop she
kicks the man out granny's elder son is
named seung-heon he works an average job
at a prestigious company and is always
disrespected by his co-workers when
seung-heon was little granny's debt
collectors used to yell at him because
of her on being sentenced to prison she
left him in an orphanage because of
which he has hated her his entire life
seung-heon lives with his wealthy
in-laws and has been working hard to
someday buy a house of his own and move
in with his wife and son somewhere else
a media company thinks of an exciting
television program to bring in revenue
they organize a non-censored cursing
competition the only problem is that
they are short on participants pd yang
and her associate are given the
responsibility to look for the top
insulters of the city granny's younger
son jooheon is unemployed and lives off
his wife's income they welcome granny in
their house mostly because she hands his
wife a bundle of money as a gift granny
should probably use that money to pay
her damn debts granny finds out that her
elder son is living with his in-laws
she knows that he dislikes her but still
wants to meet him so she pays a man to
land her the job as a maid at his house
the next day she goes to his house for
the first time and is briefed about her
job by the previous maid the maid also
mentions that seung-heon's mother-in-law
wants the housemaid to be fluent in
english granny says a few english words
to make her believe she is in fact
fluent although it is difficult to work
as a maid at her age she doesn't mind as
long as she gets to see her son
daughter-in-law and grandson for the
past few days p.d yang and her associate
have been looking for foul-mouthed
people of the town they hear about
granny from someone and set out to look
for her granny finally meets seung-heon
but he isn't happy to see her he ignores
her entirely and gets in a car with the
chairman of his company and his
mother-in-law the chairman also sees
granny who reminds him of a kind lady he
had met once when he was in prison the
lady had stopped him from committing
suicide so he has always been thankful
to her granny cannot sleep at night
because of her son's indifference to her
arrival she walks to a nearby park and
screams profanities to no one petey yang
who is also at the park hears her but
cannot find her in the dark this
conflict is ridiculous starting the next
day she and her associates stay at the
park waiting for the foul-mouthed old
lady the next day sung seung-heon's
mother-in-law brings an english teacher
to test if granny lied about her
qualifications the teacher quickly
catches up to her lie and reveals she
does not know how to speak english the
mother-in-law is furious and wants to
fire her but seungheon's wife insists
they do not need someone who speaks in
english just to do household work when
granny returns home that day she hears
jooheon and his wife arguing it turns
out that he gambled away the money she
had given them jooheon and granny go to
the park where he reveals that he needs
a lot of money to pay off his debt just
then pd yang finds granny and asks her
to be in their show at first granny
declines the offer but pd yang doesn't
stop trying to persuade her eventually
she agrees to do it for the three
hundred thousand dollar prize money
finally the auditions for the swearing
competition take place the judges
dismiss most of the contestants because
they do not match their standards when
it is granny's turn to audition she is
blinded by the spotlight and cannot
speak come on granny you can do it safe
one of the judges makes fun of her for
being old which triggers her she curses
her heart out at the judge and gets
instantly selected somewhere else sung
hyun's wife and his mother-in-law go to
meet the chairman's wife to maintain
their social status while waiting for
her they discuss granny's behavior and
how she lied about her qualifications as
they talk the mother-in-law also
suggests the wife divorce a loser like
sung hyun they mistakenly leave granny's
cv with her picture on the table when
the chairman's wife arrives a while
later she recognizes granny as an old
friend who she respects the most it
turns out that although she is wealthy
she had once stolen granny's money and
was the reason that she had to leave her
kids and go to jail she feels very sorry
for granny and plans to meet her to ask
for forgiveness at work when everyone is
out granny gets some alone time with her
grandson for the first time she picks
him up from the bus stop and takes him
to the park the kid's parents are always
busy so he is delighted to finally have
someone to play with they spend the
entire day together playing and learning
when his mother returns home she sees
that the kid is silently eating food on
his own she is impressed by granny's
skills because it has always been
difficult for her to feed her son granny
teaches her a few tricks about parenting
after which she decides not to fire her
the next day they shoot the first
episode of the cursing competition
granny has to go against several
youngsters but she is confident because
no one is as good as her she makes some
of them cry with only her words one of
them even passes out not being able to
handle the profanities nothing beats
insults from the 50s she also goes
against a beatboxer who makes
inappropriate hand gestures just when
everyone thinks she is about to lose
this one she claps back with even
filthier movements that make the guy
almost cry at the end of the episode
granny gathers many fans around korea
because of her the program is a hit the
chairman's wife who has stolen money
from the granny sees her on tv and finds
out where she lives while working at
sung heon's home she makes sure to try
to reconnect with him she also discovers
a photo album in his cabin with an old
picture of her this makes her hope that
her son will eventually forgive her one
day she meets the chairman's wife and
her friend on the street the women beg
for forgiveness for their deeds although
their mistake had caused granny to be
separated from her children she forgives
them and tells them that she doesn't
want the money back in the next episode
of the cursing competition a lawyer is
made to go against a girl it is almost
impossible to win against the lawyer who
uses his knowledge of the constitution
to argue meanwhile granny goes against a
rapper who freestyles his diss but after
cursing at the audience to yell louder
and hyping them up granny wins this
round as well the producer of the show
is over the moon after the broadcast the
ratings have skyrocketed because of
granny to stir more drama he sends
people to find out about granny's past
so her opponents can use it to diss her
as soon as twitter exists this producer
is getting cancelled one day granny is
with seung-heon's wife visiting the
market when she sees a shopkeeper
hitting his wife she calls him out for
it and throws profanities at him the
people around her start to recognize her
so she quickly walks back to the house
granny and seung-heon's wife start to
get along well moreover seung-heon's son
treats her like his own grandmother even
though he doesn't know it seungheon on
the other hand has finally gathered
enough money to buy a house he asks his
real estate agent for a house with three
bedrooms just in case granny wants to
stay with them he too is opening up to
his mother for the next episode granny
is made to go against the lawyer while
pretending to be his wife she makes fun
of the size of his appendage making
everyone laugh her jokes turn into memes
which makes her even more famous she
wins against the unbeatable lawyer and
reaches the final round the lawyer is
enraged by the loss and humiliation he
had to face on national television to
take revenge on granny he digs up her
past and finds out that she abandoned
her sons and is an ex-con soon the word
goes around and the man granny kicked
out of the train testifies against her
on tv as the news spreads random people
joined the bandwagon coming out with
false accusations against her people
find out that seung-heon and joo heon
are her sons seung-heon's colleague who
already thought he was a loser makes fun
of him because of his mother this
triggers the trauma that seung-heon has
been suppressing his entire life
moreover his mother-in-law also finds
out about his mother and blames him for
bringing his ex-con mother into their
house taking the opportunity she
declares that her daughter is divorcing
him soon what a great day for seungheon
granny gets on her knees and begs the
woman not to ruin her son's life just
because she is mad at her however the
mother-in-law kicks her out of the house
after insulting her when granny returns
home jooheon is furious at her he hadn't
known that she had been working as a
maid at seungheon's house he hates the
fact that his mother favors his elder
brother more than him the two get into a
huge argument when suddenly granny
starts to cough uncontrollably jooheon
and his wife go to the doctor and show
him the medicine that granny takes only
to find out that she has a weak heart
and probably has had a few heart attacks
while she was in prison that night
granny gets a call from seung-heon's
wife who informs her that he hasn't
returned home granny goes to his work
and asks his colleagues about him but
they too have no answer she doesn't
agree to leave until they tell her where
he is which causes a huge fuss in the
office the chairman notices this and
comes out of his cabin he instantly
recognizes granny as the woman who saved
his life in prison he kneels in front of
her in gratitude surprising his
employees they finally listened to
granny's request and kindly tell her
that they haven't seen sung hyun since
the previous day meanwhile outside the
studio a crowd has gathered to protest
against the cursing competition claiming
that it is immoral for giving an ex-con
a platform the last episode is about to
begin but granny hasn't come to the set
in the following scene we see seung-heon
in his car nothing in his life is going
right so he has decided to commit
suicide he drives into a wall and falls
unconscious in the meantime granny goes
to the studio but is clearly not ready
for the last round on top of that she
has to go against another old woman who
hasn't lost a single round until now the
competition gets more difficult for
granny when it is announced that they
have to fight like a mother and son her
opponent goes as a son and insults her
but when it is granny's turn to speak
she stays silent a man from the audience
throws an egg to her face humiliating
her in front of everyone she speaks for
the first time and claims that everyone
who is cursing at her right now is right
instead of insulting the opponent granny
explains how she has been a horrible
mother to her kids at last she breaks
down crying and says that she loves her
children dearly as she gives the
heartfelt speech seung-heon crawls out
of the car and is saved by people nearby
granny's words inspire many people from
around the country they start to yell
profanities at everything that has been
bothering them in life granny's opponent
goes silent and she finally wins the
competition however she vomits blood and
falls unconscious right after she is
admitted to the hospital where sung heon
comes to see her and calls her mom for
the first time in decades granny is now
surrounded by her family who loves her
dearly she soon gets well and comes out
of the hospital as a celebrity the women
who had stolen from her agree to return
all the money with interest seung-heon's
mother-in-law sees granny's connections
and apologizes to her at the end of the
movie she gets inside a car to fly to
america for heart surgery
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching